[Music]
open the cloud storage browser in the
Google cloud platform console and click
create bucket give the bucket a globally
unique name this name is publicly
visible so don't include sensitive
information choose regional for storage
class and choose US East one for
location click create which will create
your bucket now that we've created a
bucket let's upload an image into the
new bucket click upload files and select
the file you want to store after the
upload completes you should see the file
name size type and last modified date in
the bucket in order to share the file
create a publicly accessible URL for it
click the drop down menu associated with
a file and select edit permissions click
the add item button in the new row
that's added enter user for the entity
column enter all users in the name
column and enter reader in the Access
column click Save you'll now see there's
a link icon for the object clicking it
will reveal the object's public URL now
your files online for everyone to see
congratulations
you